[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم تبنى تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
اسقاط طائره الركاب الروسيه في شبه جزيره
سيناء وقال التنظيم ان العمليه جاءت ردا
على الغارات الروسيه التي تسببت في مقتل
مئات السوريين على حد تعبيره لكن مسؤولين
مسؤولين مصريين وروس شككوا في تبني
التنظيم للعمليه نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في
محورين ما الرسائل التي يبعثها تبني تنظيم
الدوله اسقاط الطائره الروسيه في شبه
جزيره
سيناء وما التداعيات المحتمله لهذه الخطوه
على مستقبل السياسه الروسيه في
المنطقه
لم يبدي الطرفان الروسي والمصري حماسه
لقبول تبني تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه اسقاط
طائره الركاب الروسيه من طراز اير باس
321 في سيناء فبينما قال وزير النقل
الروسي انه لا يمكن اعتبار الروايه الخاصه
بالتنظيم دقيقه نفى رئيس الوزراء المصري
شريف اسماعيل وجود انشطه غير عاديه حسب
تعبيره قد تكون وراء الحادث بين ان
الطرفين احتفظ بمسافه من تاكيد في روايه
التنظيم لملابسات الحادث حين اكد ان
الصندوق الاسود هو الفيصل في تحديد سبب
سقوط او اسقاط الطائره تقرير زياد
بركات تبكي اولجا او نتاشا او ايا كان
اسمها فثم فجيعه حدثت وثمه قريب قتل وهو
من لحم ودم وذكريات يا
اللهبي يا الله ثمت اخرون يبكون في مكان
اخر وسبا اخرى لم تسقط طائره هنا في حلب
او ادلب او دوما ليبكي هؤلاء اقاربهم بل
ان ثمه طائرات صدف انها روسيه تسقط وتقصف
فيموت مدنيون هم تماما مثل اقارب اولجا او
نتاشا من لحم ودم
وذكريات تلك هي موسكو وقد اخذت مكان
واشنطن في الشرق الاوسط قبل ايام قليله
فقط شيعت اول قتلاها في حربها مع بشار على
شعبه على ما يصف منتقد التدخل الروسي
لاحقا قط لها طائره فيهرع تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه في سيناء لتبني الحادث وذاك من
اقوى فروع التنظيم في المنطقه وثمه ما
يتردد عن سلاح متقدم حصل عليه من خارج
الحدود المصريه قد يكون بعضه قادرا على
اسقاط طائرات على علو محدد فهل اسقط
التنظيم حقا الطائره الروسيه في التفاصيل
ثمه ما يريب فالطائر بحسب الشركه المالكه
سقطت عموديا وانقسمت الى جزئين وهي كما
تؤكد الشركه نفسها خضعت لكل لاجراءات
الصيانه وفقا لمعايير الطيران الدوليه اما
طيارها
فمحتارة انتقام تنظيم الدوله من الروس على
خلفيه تدخلهم في سوريا فهل ثمه من يريد
للروس ان ياتوا الى هنا الى سيناء ليتور
طوا اكثر في الشرق الاوسط ويدفع الثمن
باهظا وهل يكون النظام المصري مثلا يرغب
في ذلك لتحارب موسكو بالنيابه عنه وليقدم
نفسه باعتباره ضحيه قوا تستوجب تحالفا
دوليا لالحاق الهزيمه بها وثمت احتمالات
اخرى فربما يكون خصوم موسكو الاقليمي
والدوليون وبعضهم متنفذ وربما ذو ص مكتومه
مع تنظيم الدوله او سواه يريد ان يبعث
الرسائل خشنه للروس بان يلعبوا بعيدا ايا
يكون الامر فان ثمه قتلى روسا سيعودون في
اكفانهم الى بلداتهم وذاك قد يكون بسبب
سياسات حكومتهم خارج الحدود من سوريا الى
مصر وسواها من دول يقتل فيها الناس على
ايدي
حكامهم موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفين من
نواكشط السيد ابو حفص الموريتاني مفتي
تنظيم القاعده سابقا ومن موسكو الخبير في
الشؤون الامنيه والعسكريه بافل فلجن هاور
مرحبا بكما والسؤال للسيد ابو حفص سيد ابو
حفص بدايه هل تقبل امكانيه قيام تنظيم
الدوله
الاسلاميه ولايه سيناء يعني فرعه في شبه
جزيره سيناء امكانيه قيامه باسقاط طائره
مدنيه على هذا الارتفاع
الشاهق بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم في البدايه لا استطيع ان اؤكد او
انفي
ما اعلنه لا انا سالتك تقبل امكانيه لكن
انا لم اسال عن النفي والتاكيد هذا في علم
الغيب اي ممكن يعني تنظيم الدوله حقيقه
سواء كان فرعه في سينا او الدوله المركز
في العراق وسوريا اثبت كفاءه عاليه
في قدرته وفي امكانياته سواء امكانيات
الارضيه وامكانيات الجويه يعني يقال انه
في الاسبوع الماضي ان هنالك طائره مسيره
بتحكم عن بعد التنظيم اسقطها اسقطها الجيش
العراقي والتنظيم اثبت كفاءه عاليه ولكن
لا نستطيع ان نجم بذلك ثم انه اسقاط طائره
مدنيه ليس عمليه صعيبه جدا يعني الطائرات
المدنيه هدف سهل ل بعض المضادات الارضيه
غير المتقدمه جدا يعني فهذا وارد جدا ثم
انه بيانات التنظيم التي يعلنها ويتبنى
فيها بعض المسؤوليات تحضى بمصداقيه الى حد
كبير يعني ثم انه الروس والمصريون ايضا لم
ينفوا نفا جازما ولا قاطعا بيان التنظيم
الذي تبنى فيه عمليه اسقاط الطائره فهذا
وارد يعني ولكن لا نستطيع جزم بذلك سيد
فلجن هاور هل تعتقد ان هناك رساله ما من
وراء هذا الاعلان السريع
والمتعجلون فرع سيناء لاسقاط الطائره
الروسيه
المدنيه
تنظيم
الدوله ادعى المسؤوليه عن هذا حتى لو لم
يقم بذلك الامر الاهم هنا هو الادله
الجنائيه من موقع تحطم الطائره والصندوق
الاسود يجب استعادته والحطام ايضا كل هذا
سيعطينا صوره كامله لما حدث بالفعل
ونعم الان لا يم يمكننا ان نقصي اي احتمال
قد يكون الامر يعود الى خلل فني رغم ان
هذا الطراز 31 من ايرس هو طراز جيد من
الطائرات ولا يسقط من السماء بسهوله ايضا
هناك امكانيه لعمل تخريبي او هجوم ارهابي
او
اجهزه متفجره كانت قد هربت على متن
الطائره اذا ما كان هناك اخراق امني في
شرم الشيخ او هناك احتمال لاستخدام صاروخ
مضاد لطائرات من سيناء ولكن الان كل
الخيارات مفتوحه انا سالت تحديدا عن
الرسائل التي يمكن ان يبعث بها هذا التبني
السريع من قبل تنظيم الدوله
للعمليه الشرق الاوسط هناك نزعه دائما
بتبني المسؤوليه
دائما وخاصه بالنسبه للهجمات
الارهابيه في روسيا ليس هناك هذا الامر
ولكن في الشرق الاوسط هناك تبني للمسؤوليه
واحيانا من مصادر مختلفه لذات الهجوم نعم
قاموا بذلك بسرعه باصدار الاعلان ولكن هذا
ليس العامل الذي يحدد جرى الا ان الادله
و هي ما سيبحث فيه المختصون في قطاع
الطيران ولكن التهديد الارهابي قائم وهذا
احتمال ممكن شيخ ابو حفص يعني بنظره سريعه
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وهي
بالمناسبه نؤكد انها ان هذا ليس معيارا
دقيقا لقياس الراي العام لكن في المجمل
انا اقول لك بالنظره السريعه على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي نجد ان كثيرا من ابناء
هذه المنطقه في ظل المشاعر الجياشه
والاجواء الملتهبه والظروف المتقده في
سوريا بفعل التدخل العسكري الروسي تجد
كثيرا من الشبان المتسرعين يبدون حماستهم
لمثل هذه العمليات وفرحهم بهذا في حين
يتعقل البعض او يتروى البعض ويشير الى ان
استهداف طائره مدنيه عمل اجرامي بكل
المعايير هل تعتقد ان تبني تنظيم الدوله
لهذه العمليه يمكن ان يضيف اليه حاضنه
شعبيه يمكن ان يضيف اليه انصارا
جددا لا شك يعني هذا مما لا شك فيه ولا
ريب
اي المنطقه منطقه ملتهبه اصلا
و ملتهبه محليا تعيش ثورات وانقلابات
وتحركات شعبيه المنطقه تعيش احتلال
اسرائيلي وتعيش جرائم يوميه يرتكب هال
الاحتلال الصهيوني ضد الشعب الفلسطيني
تعيش احتقان طائفي ومذهبي
وتعيش اكثر من ذلك عدد من القتلى يوميا
يكاد يوازي عدد قتلى الطائره يعني العالم
اليوم وقف وحبس انفاسه مع عدد ضحايا
الطائره السوريون الشعب السوري في كل يوم
يدفن تقريبا مثل هذا العدد من ابنائه من
النساء والاطفال والشيوخ وهذا ما يهيئ
المناخ لتقبل اي عمل من هذا القبيل حتى
تقبله من لا يؤمن به
يعني التوتر والاحتقان يجعل الناس يتقبلون
عمليات من هذا القبيل وان كانوا لا
يوافقون عليها اصلا يعني في الظروف
العاديه لا شك ان اذا ثبت تنظيم الدوله
تبني تنظيم الدوله للعمليه اذا ثبت انه هو
من قام باسقاط الطائره ان هذا سوف يعطيه
مصداقيه جديده وشعبيه جديده شبيهه
بالشعبيه التي حظي بها تنظيم القاعده بعد
عمليات الحا من سبتمبر من كثير من
المسلمين الذين لا يوافقون على اصل
العمليات لكن في الامه المكلومه والمجروحه
وتتعرض للظلم يعني انت تقول ان ان التدخل
العسكري الخشن لروسيا او المدان شعبيا في
هذه المنطقه من قبل روسيا داخل سوريا جعل
روسيا هدفا مشروعا لمثل هذا مثل هذه
التنظيمات
يعني جعله مشروعا عند مثل هذه التنظيمات
وجعل ايضا عمليات من هذا القبيل مقبوله
شعبيه عند كثير من الناس وان كنت انا
شخصيا لا ارى انه تستهدف الاهداف المدنيه
الا ان هذا كلام يقولون كلام هذا كلام
تنظير خارج يعني السياق وخارج الواقع لان
نحن في هذا اليوم الذي سقطت فيه الطائره
او اسقطت هنالك ضحايا كثور جدا يعني
وضحايا ما بين الامس واول امس في حماه وفي
حلب وفي ادلب ضحايا من المدنيين والنساء
والاطفال اكثر من عدد قتلى الطائره الذين
سقطوا وهذا هو العمل وان كان غير مقبولا
غير مقبول الا انه مفهوم عند كثير من
الناس الذين تظهر تظهر مواقفهم من خلال
مواقع التواصل الاج انا اقول الروس نعم
سيد فلجن هاور يعني مع التسليم بان الراي
العام في روسيا ليس من الموجهات الاساسيه
للسياسات الخاصه بالدوله
ا لكن في كل الاحوال كيف يمكن ان يستقبل
المجتمع الروسي نب مثل هذا تنظيم الدوله
يعلن اسقاط طائره مدنيه روسيه ربما يقول
البعض ما كان اغنانا عن التدخل في هذه
المنطقه حتى لا نصبح هدفا لمثل هذه
التنظيمات والبعض الاخر يمكن ان يصدق
روايه بوتين في ان التدخل جاء لحمايه
روسيا من الارهاب ايهما يمكن ان يكون ارجح
لديك عندما بدات العمليه الروسيه في سوريا
كان هناك كثير من القلق في اوساط الراي
العام الروسي بان هذا سيجلب علينا هجمات
ارهابيه في روسيا وضد
الروس المواطنين وهذا اذا ما ثبت بانه
هجوم
ارهابي
فهذا سيكون له اثار وتداعيات سيئه في
الراي العام الروسي اذا اعتقد ان وجود
السلطات الروسيه
والمصريه امر مهم في التوصل الى الحقيقه
ولكن من الصعب على البلدين ان يقرا بان
هذا هجوم ارهابي بالنسبه لمصر هذا يعرقل
قطاع السياحه ويؤثر عليه سلبا والروس
سيرون ربطا مباشرا بين قصف روسيا لسوريا و
ما حدث انما كان هذا هجوما ارهابيا على
الطائره
اذا الان الراي العام الروسي يدعم تحركات
بوتين في سوريا ولكن هذا طالما انه ليس
هناك اي ضحايا بين الروس وينظرون الى
التحركات بانها ستاتي بالنصر لكن اذا ما
كان هناك ضحايا بين صفوف الروس فربما
سيتغير الراي العام الروسي ارجو منكم ان
تبقى معي فاصل قصير مشاهدينا الاعزاء
نناقش بعده تاثيرات تبني تنظيم الدوله
اسقاط الطائرات الروسيه في سيناء على
سياسات موسكو المستقبليه في المنطقه نرجو
ان تبقوا
معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الاعزاء في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش تبني تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه اسقاط الطائرا الروسيه في سيناء
وتاثيرات هذه المواقف على مستقبل السياسه
الروسيه في المنطقه والسؤال لضيفنا من
موسكو الخبير في الشؤون الامنيه والعسكريه
السيد بافل فلجن هاور سيد فلجن هاور يعني
ذكرت ان الراي العام يمكن ان تكون له في
روسيا يمكن ان تكون له نظره سلبيه تجاه
التدخل الع العسكري الروسي في سوريا اذا
ما توالى توافد الصناديق التي تحمل جثامين
روس بسبب او من جراء هذا التدخل العسكري
ماذا عن النظام الروسي ماذا عن الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين وسياساته المستقبليه في
المنطقه بعد حادث كهذا اذا اثبت الصندوقان
الاسودان ان هناك يعني شبهه جنائيه
فيه
[موسيقى]
بوتين في عوامه الطويله في الحكم في حالات
كهذه دائما يدحض بما
يجري لغير صالحه اذا
ف التعامل
هذا سوف يتم من خلال تحركات بوتين لدحض
هذه الروايه ولكنه رغم هذا ينصت الى الراي
العام وعلى الارجح سيتم استخدام حمله
دعائيه جديه تسخر لها كل الطاقات وذلك
لاعاده الراي العام الروسي لسابق عهده
ولكن هذه ستكون اخبار سيئه اذا ما تكرر
مثل هذا
الحدث سواء كان هذا عن طريق السياحه
الروسيه او وجود عسكريون عسكريين روس في
سوريا او حتى على مصر وتاثيرات ذلك عليها
ماذا عن التقارب المصري الروسي الذي
يعتبره قطاع من المصريين غير مبرر في هذه
المرحله ما الذي يمكن ان تجنيه مصر من
التقارب مع روسيا هل تعتقد ان هذا التقارب
سيستمر اذا ما ثبت وجود شبهه جنائيه في
الحادث
العلاقات السيئه قد تاتي وقد ناقشت هذا مع
دبلوماسي هنا في موسكو مصر تعتمد كثيرا
على
السعوديه في التمويل المالي
والدعم اذا مصر لا يمكن لها ان تقوم بدور
مستقل حيادي رغم ان هناك
علاقات
طيب الان بين الرئيس السيسي والرئيس بوتين
سيد ابو حفص الموريتاني من تعتقد انه يمكن
ان يجني ثمار حدث كهذا اذا ما ثبت انه تم
بفعل فاعل يعني مصر اقتصادها متداعي
بالفعل والسياحه ليست في حاجه الى مزيد من
الانتكاسات وبالفعل هناك
شركه هناك شركه طيران كب من كبريات
الشركات اعلنت انها لن تسير رحلات فوق شبه
الجزيره زيره سيناء بعد هذا الحادث هل
تعتقد ان في الجانب السياسي يمكن ان
يستفيد منه النظام المصري لتشديد القبضه
الامنيه على سبيل المثال في شبه جزيره
سيناء او في مصر
كلها انا اريد ان انبه اولا الى انه قضيه
ثبوت او نفي اسقاط التنظيم للطائره قد لا
هذه حقيقه قد لا نصل اليها لانه اذا تبجين
للروس والمصريين ان التنظيم هو فعلا من
اسقط الطائره فهذه حقيقه لا يعلنون عنها
لانها ليست من مصلحه النظام ولا من مصلحه
النظام المصري ولا من مصلحه ايضا النظام
الروسي هذه مساله المساله الاخرى انا
اتمنى ان يكون اول من يجني حقيقه ثمار
عمليه من هذا القبيل هو الروس بان يلتقطوا
الرساله وينسحب من
المنطقه المنطقه حق الدول الكبر لا تنسحب
لا تنسحب من المعارك بمثل هذا الحادث
ونظرائه انت تدري هذا يعني بالعكس عندما
وقع حادث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر جيشت
الولايات الم متحده العالم كله وليس فقط
امريكا
لمحاربه بقاع من العالم الاسلامي بحجه
مكافحه
الارهاب صحيح انا اقول هذا الحادث يعني هو
ممكن يستفيد منه اطراف مختلفه سوف يستفيد
يستفيد منه تنظيم الدوله بان يكتسب شعبيه
جديده وسوف يستفيد منه في التضييق
الاقتصادي على النظام المصري بانه سوف
يحرمه من عائدات السياحه ومن حركه الطيران
سوف يعطي مصداقيه جديده للتنظيم سوف
يستفيد منه ايضا الت النظام المصري بان
يثبت نفسه بانه راع وحام وواقف في وجه
الارهاب وانه يحتاج الدعم والمسانده من
الشرق كما يحتاجه من الغرب وهذا يعني مصدر
من مصادر التمويل وصادر الدعم السياسي
لنظام مهتز في الداخل كما كشفت الانتخابات
الاخيره سوف يعني لكن انا الذي اريد ان
اقوله يعني ان الروس يجب ان يلتقطوا
الرساله مبكرا الروس تدخلوا في افغانستان
وخرجوا منها بعد ث مان سنوات وزياده خرجوا
منها ب 50,000 قتيل وضعف هذا العدد من
الجرحى واكثر من 400 طائره محطمه واكثر من
5000 دبابه وعشرات الالاف وخرجوا منه
مهزومين بغير فائده فكان سبب يعني خروجهم
من الاتح خروجهم من افغانستان سبب انهيار
الاتحاد السوفيتي بل وانهيار المعسكر
الشرقي جميعا يعني انا اقول يعني هنالك من
يسكت الان عن الروس وربما يشجعهم عن قصد
لاغراق في المنطقه الامريكيون جربوا من
قبل في المنطقه فيجب ان ياخذ الروؤس الدرس
ويستفيدوا منه مبكرا المنطقه لا تحتاج صب
زيت جديد على نارها يجب ان تفهم هذه
الرسائل ويجب ان يعيد الروس حساباتهم في
المنطقه الناس الذين لا يوافقون على تنظيم
الدوله ولا يوافقون على سياساته ويرونها
مخالفه شرعيه مستعدون للسكوت والتغاضي عن
اعمال يقوم بها من هذا القبيل اذا كانت
تشكل نكايه في الروس الذين غزو سوريا
ويرتكبون جرائم يوميه ضد الشعب السوري سيد
فيلن هاور يعني في الانباء التي تلت
الحادث مباشره النائب العام المصري يوافق
على لجنه او اشراك الروس في التحقيقات
الخاصه بهذا الحادث هل تعتقد اننا يمكن ان
نشهد تعاونا عسكريا لمكافحه ما يسمى
الارهاب في شبه جزيره سيناء مستقبلا بين
روسيا ومصر على غرار هذا التعاون في
التحقيقات والتعاون في الجوانب الامنيه
والمخابراتيه
هذا يبدو الان بعيد المنال طبعا المحققون
الروس سوف يعملون مع المصريين بشان ما حدث
لهذه الطائره وامل ان لا يكون هناك
تغطيه وان الحقائق ستظهر في نهايه المطاف
دون تستر
ولكن الجنود
الروس انما كانوا سيذهبوا الى سيناء
ويشاركون مع
الجنود المصريين في سيناء او ان يقاتلوا
الى جانب الاسد في سوريا هذا بعيد المنال
ولكن بالطبع سيكون هناك تعاون بشان هذا
الحادث وربما بعض التعاون في مكافحه
الارهاب ولكن ليس شيئا مذهلا ك خوض الحرب
معا سيد ابو حفص فيما يتعلق بالتح
الديمقراطي في المنطقه وفي مصر تحديدا هل
تعتقد ان لمثل هذا الحادث انعكاس على هذه
العمليه انا اعتقد ان الحادث يعني هو يزيد
من تعقيدات موجوده اصلا في المنطقه كما
قلت يعني تعقيدات مختلفه و وفاعله فيها
اطراف ايضا متعدده وهذا يهيئ لمزيد من
التوترات ومن العمليات من هذا القبيل يعني
انا اقول حتى في ظروف اقل توتر من هذا و و
من قبل اطراف اكثر قدره على التحكم في
يعني في امكانياتها وقدراتها واسلحتها
حصلت حوادث من هذا القبيل يعني نحن ما
نسينا بعد حادثه اسقاط الطائره الماليزيه
في شرق اوكرانيا والروس وحلفاؤها غير بعيد
عن ذلك ولم ننسى ايضا اسقاط الطائره
الايرانيه المدنيه من قبل البحريه
الامريكيه في الخليج قبل عده
سنوات المنطقه لما تكون محتقنه وتكون
متوتره وتكون ويزداد اليها عامل جديد عامل
اشعال جديد تكون مهيئه لمزيد من عمليات من
هذا القبيل
وا العاقل العاقل الذي يبحث عن مصلحته هو
من يى بنفسه عن الغرق في مثل هذه المنطقه
وهذه حقيقه رساله يجب ان ت الاعمل بمقتضى
سيد فلجن هاور سواء ثبت دقه تبني التنظيم
لهذه العمليه او لا هل تعتقد ان روسيا
يمكن ان تنجح في تسويق نفسها شريكا في في
الحرب الدوليه على
الارهاب نعم هذا الهدف الاستراتيجي الروسي
اي تشكيل تحالف واسع ضد تنظيم الدوله واذا
ما ثبت بان تنظيم الدوله يقف
وراء هذه الكارثه التي حلت بالطائره
الروسيه فان هذا يعني بان روسيا ستستخدم
هذا الحدث كنقطه
جدليه تدعم موقفها لدعم الاسد ولتشكيل
تحالف اوسع ضد الارهاب شكرا جزيلا لك
السيد بافل فلجن هاور الخبير في الشؤون
الامنيه والعسكريه كان ضيفنا من موسكو
واشكر كذلك ضيفنا من من وكشط في موريتانيا
السيد ابو حفص الموريتاني مفتي تنظيم
القاعده سابقا بهذا مشاهدينا الاعزاء
تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
نلتقي باذن الله تعالى في في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد السلام عليكم ورحمه
[موسيقى]
الله